Hey everybody.
Thanks so much for joining
us today for our workflows with
Posit Team session.
If this is your first
time joining us,
we do host these workflows
the last Wednesday of every month.
And so if you ever wanna
go back and check out the
recordings, I think we've had
about seven of them so far.
But today you will learn
from Gordon Shotwell, Senior
software engineer at Posit
who is joining us to show how
to use Posit Connect as an
end to end Python platform for
hosting internal
machine learning models.
I'll be hanging around
in the background here.
So if you have any questions,
feel free to put
them into the chat.
I'll also put a slido in
there where you can ask anonymously.
But with that, thanks
again for joining us,
and I'll turn it
over to Gordon.
My name is Gordon Shawwell.
I'm a software engineer at Posit,
and I mostly work
on shiny for Python.
But before I work at Posit,
I was I worked in industry
building, tools for training,
deploying, and monitoring
machine learning models.
And I learned a couple
of patterns with Posit Connect
that I think are
particularly useful,
and I wanted to go through
some of those, today.
So let's just get started
by taking a look at this,
modeling code. And
this is a very,
simple,
maybe probably in these days,
this day and age, primitive,
text classification model that,
basically classifies text based on the
words that are in that sentence.
Determine whether it's
about electronics or not.
And here we have sort
of the modeling code,
break the model into
training and test set,
fit the model and then
print out some accuracy,
some model statistics.
And the question here is, say
I'm happy with this model,
and I wanna share it
with other people.
How should I do
that? In particular,
how should I share it with
all the different groups of people
that might need to interact
with either this model or the
data that underlies
this model somehow.
So this is a kind of,
the way I would sort of break
it up in terms of this sort of
imaginary situation where
I'm building a model,
I wanna share it
with other people.
And I can think of five groups
that,
that
need to use this model. So
the first group is me, like,
the modelers me and my the
team of people who actually, like,
generated this model.
Second group is leadership,
who might want to get model
statistics or have a sense of
how this model is performing
on the latest set of data.
Third one is the data team.
These might be people who use
code to
score the text that
they're encountering in their own
datasets. And then finally,
we have these two other two
groups. One is a
group of annotators.
This is a group of
people who might be,
annotating data to provide me
with more training data and
improve the quality
of my models.
And there's this other this
last group that's just kind of
other systems that
might come up, you know,
other group other people
using other programming languages,
maybe somebody who's working on
the website might need to call
this model for some reason.
And all these groups have
different needs and importantly
different interfaces.
So modelers and the data team,
they're probably
both using Python.
They might have some people
using R, but in this case,
in this sort of example, say
they're all using Python.
Leadership, they probably
just wanna see a static site.
You know, they don't need
something super interactive.
They just need to see something
that gives them a little print
out of statistics.
And, finally, we have
these annotators,
and they're probably
not technical.
So they're going to need a more
of a full featured web app.
And these other systems are
gonna interact with some
programming language that maybe we
don't know now or won't know
about in the future.
One of my most,
sort of important principles
when thinking about these types
of systems is this role,
which is APIs before UIs.
So when we look at
this group of people,
see that there are a few
different groups that are using
something you
might call an API.
It's a code first interaction
with this product.
We have these Python users and
these other systems, which might
use some type of code.
And the reason why I think,
APIs before UIs is such a
good rule is that code interfaces
are way easier to
build than GUI.
They just have
fewer parameters.
You don't need to worry
about centering something or making
the UI kind of intuitive.
You can just build the code
and have people interact with the
code. Because they're
easier to build,
they're easier to
change and iterate upon.
This means that if you're kind
of working mostly on an API,
you're gonna be able to
make more changes more quickly to
center in on the right
interaction, the right data
model, and the right
type of user flow,
for your particular product.
And my experience doing this for a
number of years is that a good
API will usually create a good
UI, both in terms of, like,
the simplicity of the code,
and also how intuitive it is.
Once you've kind of
centered on that right, API,
the right interaction
for your problem,
the GUI that serves that
type of interaction is pretty
obvious most of the time.
The opposite is not true.
I've seen a lot of
times people build,
a GUI first And in doing that,
they kind of just sort of
throw different things into some type
of programming data model or
some type of of interface.
And trying to build a
intuitive code interface
using those same data
structures can be really awkward.
And so if you ever tried
to analyze web data as a data
scientist, this kind of why.
You got this big giant blob
of date of JSON that's not
particularly well structured,
for your purpose. Right?
So if you ever had the
option of building the code interface
first before doing any type
type of GUI work, I recommend
doing doesn't always happen, but
in this case, we do. Right?
We have these these three
groups of people are interested in
code. They're also probably
our earliest stakeholders,
so we might wanna
serve them first.
Okay. So one way of
distributing this model is,
to use a Python package. Right?
I could put this model
in a Python package,
and have that
package be installed
from something like Posit
package manager or nexus or
some other, package
hosting system.
But this creates
a few problems.
There's and I would say
there's maybe there's three main problems.
The first is that packages
are necessarily really hard to
authenticate and authorize.
So usually when you look at,
internal repositories,
They're like PyPI
like repositories.
They don't have
particularly sophisticated security controls
on who can download, those packages.
But the bigger problem is
that once those packages are
downloaded from
those repositories,
they're just in the wild.
There's no real way for to
control who has access to them.
We can't create fine grained
controls, for example,
give some people access to
one Python function in the package
and other people access
to another one. And if,
the individual human who
just downloaded that,
package shares it
inappropriately
or leaves their laptop
open and unintended.
Anything that's in there
including the model or any type
of data that's on that in
that package is gonna be exposed. Right?
So if we're working on a
model that maybe includes some
sensitive intellectual property or
might encode some sensitive
data or expose some
sensitive data,
That's gonna be a really
big problem. Right?
We wanna have the ability to
authenticate the model when it's called.
And the second big problem
with packages is that they always
require user input to update.
So if I were to distribute
this model in a, Python package just
by itself, If I ever changed
the model or changed, you know,
updated it or changed some part
of how that model is called,
I would need to ask all of
my downstream users to update
their installation.
And they would need to do
that probably in a lot of places.
So they may need to update
in all the different virtual
environments they have
on their computer.
If they deployed assets
to Posit Connect,
they would need to
update all those.
It becomes an enormous hassle.
And the final reason is
that that would need Python, right,
not probably most of our
users are kind of comfortable using
Python, but some of
them maybe aren't.
Maybe have some R
users at my company.
Maybe there's a Scala group
that wants to call this model.
And creating Python to their
build environment is maybe
gonna cause some problems.
An,
an alternative and what I'm gonna
choose here is to use an
API. Basically,
host host this model as an
API on pause on Posit connect.
And have, some wrapper
functions that call that API.
And this is gonna give
me a couple of major advantages.
The first is that
I'm gonna solve,
I'm gonna solve all three
of the problems that I just
expressed. Right?
I'm gonna have to be able
to update that model in one place
by reuploading it
to Posit Connect.
I will be able to authenticate
access to the API, both the
top level domain,
and also I can authorize any
of the endpoints that people call.
And finally, it's gonna
be language independent.
Every programming language has the
ability to wrap and call
APIs. So if I can put
something up as an API,
then I'm gonna be able to
give access to everybody.
So I'm gonna go through
kind of the overall diagram here,
and then I'm gonna take it
piece by piece and show you the
code that I developed
for these projects.
So this is kind of the big
picture of what I'm trying to
do. And I have kind of
three groups here. So the leadership,
I have data scientists who
might use both our Python
package, and then I
have these annotators.
And I'm also showing,
the interface that these
people are going to be using.
So This leadership group,
they're gonna be looking at,
a quarto rendered
quarto document.
These data scientists are
going to be interacting,
through a Python or R
package with an API,
and then the annotators are going
to be interacting with a shiny app.
The API is gonna call
a data store, and,
I'll show you what that is,
but I would recommend probably
this should be a database that
sort of lives outside of
Connect. But everything else
can exist on Connect. And
the reason why I really love
Connect for this purpose is
that it gives me a kind of safe
space that I'm able to
deploy all these different types of
assets for all these
different customers, all these different,
users without needing to have
a lot of conversations with
either DevOps, security,
or any kind of regulatory,
situation at my company. Right?
Since I've had Posit
Connect set up,
There's this one time
investment of getting that
through all the different
layers of approval that you
need to implement
something like this.
You can secure it in a way
that is compliant with all of your
company's policies. But
once you've done that,
you can just deploy
these things to this product.
It makes it a really useful prototyping,
solution, both for,
sort of, small things,
like a shiny app or
a Jupyter notebook,
but also for
these larger interconnected systems.
Right? I can validate this
whole thing works with just me,
the data scientist
doing the work.
I don't need to involve
other people getting the
infrastructure or putting
that infrastructure.
Alright. So this is a
lot. So we're gonna start,
with this API.
And,
show you kind of the, the
endpoint for this API.
Which is, this API here.
And so you see this API is a is
a FAST API, and it has a few different
endpoints.
So I have the ability to
append training data to this,
to this this data set.
I can score the model.
I can update the model.
Can get the last,
updated date, and I can,
query the data. And what's nice
about this is that, This is,
interactive swagger
documentation.
So it'll give me kind of
some information about what this is
expecting. In this case,
it has no parameters,
and it just gives you a
successful response or gives
you a string response,
and I can try it out. So
I can just click execute.
And it's gonna
give me both the,
curl command that I used to
call this, the, the request URL
and then also the response
for this particular thing.
And for some of these, that
gets a little bit more complicated.
So I chose FAST API
for one main reason.
And the main reason that
so FAST API has a few great
benefits, like, one is that
it's very fast, but in my case,
I don't particularly care
about this being a fast API.
It's a very simple one,
so many of them are gonna
be fast enough. But what fast API
gives you is this, which is,
a clear example of what data
type this is expecting. So in
this case, it's
expecting a list,
And then,
JSON object with the with a
key value pair of text with text
annotator annotation.
These two need to be string and
this one needs to be a boolean.
And the way that is produced,
if I go back to my go over
to my API code here, is by, creating,
these
pydantic models that,
tell the API what it
should expect. So here,
I'm able to define I'm defining
this training data class,
which is just a very simple
sort of key value model with
these two these three keys
and these three value types.
And then, when I
Great. Right. My my Python
function, I'm able to,
refer to that. I'm
saying this data mean,
using type annotation to say
this data is expecting a list
of training data elements.
And that list of training
data elements is then gonna generate
this expected value.
Not only will it sort
of generate that from the
documentation perspective,
but it's going to validate that
for me. So if somebody sends
mallformed,
sends a different type of,
of payload to this API. It's
gonna give me a 422 error.
So for example,
if I take this annotator one
out here and I try executing it,
the the response I
get is a four digit.
And that what what
that means is that,
I'm the API is expecting a
particular form of data and you
didn't supply that data.
So it's gonna give you an
informative error for that without me,
the programmer needing to
write any of that validation.
I don't need to do anything.
I just need to declare in the,
FAST API type type annotation,
but that's what I'm expecting.
And then I'm gonna
get that result back.
So, I'm not gonna go through
this coach in too much detail.
This is gonna be a
pretty high level sort of architectural
planning thing, but, the basic,
but a couple of but one thing
I did wanna point out here is
that, I'm storing all this data
on an on disc SQLite database,
and that's mostly just to,
keep everything on connect without
building up too many dependencies.
But that particular if you
were doing this in reality,
I would recommend pulling
that out to another,
to another data store.
So that's kind of so the to
go through some of these models a
little I have, a
pen and (inaudible) training data,
which just takes a list of
those training data elements,
and sends them to appends
them to my, SQLite data store.
I have, a model
scoring endpoint,
which opens up the latest
model that's been that's been uploaded,
and returns a single score.
So it's taking a text,
a bit of text and
returning that score.
I have the ability
to, update this model.
So I have an update
model endpoint, which takes, both the,
machine learning model and the
vectorizer to sort of turn your
text into the right features.
And
Finally, I have a
query data endpoint,
which is just sending a query
and getting a result of that query,
and a couple of test endpoints
to just let me understand,
you know, is this API
working and things like that.
The way that you
so the way that this model
is intended to be used for the
most part is I want to
allow people to some people to upload
models, allow people some
people to append data,
and I want other people to be
able to score the model or query it.
And when I'm doing that,
I this is kind of this notion
of authorization. Right?
So I wanna be able to
sort of authenticate everybody who's joining,
who's seeing this API,
but I want I wanna authorize a
couple of people to do some endpoints.
And I'm able to do
that, with this,
this
validate and validate access function here.
So this this function is
basically asking is user user
in this control list. And
if it's not, raise a 401.
And that,
user user is generated
by this function,
which is get current user,
which just looks
for, the information
in the
header that's passed
to Posit connect.
And what that is going to allow
me to do is basically say,
get the the person who's
or viewing this API and
respond with either you can access it
or you can't, as a as a 401.
So the result of that is that,
I have a couple of endpoints
which are available to
everybody, like, score model.
So if you were to
log open this up and,
try to score this score model,
you would be able to do that.
So you could try this
out. You could say,
I am a computer.
It's probably not gonna give
me a very good score here.
But here you see I'm getting
a two hundred with the score from
that model. But if
you were to try to,
to update a model or to,
query the data, you're
going to get a 401 error.
And I'm I won't get a four
zero one error because I'm sort of
one of the people who are,
who's who's allowed to view it.
Okay. So that's the, that's
mostly the API. And,
this has a couple of benefits.
So the main couple of benefits
we've just talked about are it
allows me to authorize these
features and allows me to keep
my model in one place so
that everybody is using it.
When they call the API
is kind of keeping,
get getting the right
up to date model,
But it's not particularly
user friendly. Right?
And then and the main reason
why it's not user friendly is
that most of most data
scientists are not actually
that comfortable with,
interacting with APIs,
I would say. Right?
They don't have sort of in
the back of their mind. Like,
these are what all those
HPD status codes mean.
And,
in order to give any
kind of validation that they're calling
this API correctly,
you have to send something
back and forth to the API,
which can be a
little bit difficult.
What we really wanna do is
we wanna be able to surface errors
easily and give people
a lot of kind of, like,
hand holding to help them
through calling and interacting API properly.
Let's go back to our
diagram here. Right?
So this API usually when
you're building APIs,
you kinda wanna make them
predictable and pretty strict,
but not that friendly.
They don't it's not that
important that they'll give you
great error messages or sort of
guide you along a happy path.
And in order to
give that sort of
hand holding, get
that sort of, like,
ergonomics that you want when
you're building a sort of
delightful user experience.
It's usually a good idea to
kind of wrap that API in a
package of some kind.
This could be package
of any programming language, right,
because this API is generic.
But in this case, I'm
gonna do just a Python one.
So I have my Python package here,
and this package has just one class.
And this is the way that
I personally really like,
writing API wrappers, which
is I have, an init method
that populates the top level
URL and the headers. This is
really useful. For example, if
I wanted to change this URL,
I would have changed
in one place,
or if I wanted to
develop against a local running,
I could set this
URL to local host.
And then I typically have
methods that are for each
HTTP request type that I'm
gonna use. In this case,
I'm only using post and get.
And,
the reason why I do this
is because otherwise you kind of
end up writing basically this
code over and over again,
with all of your
particular functions.
So I usually have a a post get.
If I had other methods in
my API, I would write those.
And the purpose of these these
methods is to first use that,
that request type to call
an API with a kind of,
with the right authentication
headers, and just,
keyword arguments, and then
to handle those responses.
In this case, I
want to surface, basically, that,
get if if it's four zero one,
give an extended Python error
that says you don't have access
to this endpoint. And
if it's two hundred,
or if it's not two hundred,
just give them the error code
and say, unexpected status
code. It's not your fault.
It's the API's fault.
And for the get endpoint,
it's also gonna decode it
to return the actual result.
So start off so I usually
start off by writing those sort of
high level methods and
then write more particular methods
that give level,
a little bit more
handholding. So in this case,
I have this upload data,
argument that uploads
a Panda's data frame.
And what that does
is, first of all,
it gives you checks if it
has the right columns. Right?
So rather than sending
it and giving you know,
some HTTP error saying, like,
this is the wrong data type.
Wanna sort of stop that before I send
it to the API before I do that post.
And what I'll do is I'll sort
of give a check that they have
the right these right column
names. And then if they do,
I will serialize that into a dictionary
and then post that to the endpoint.
So this is how I would
upload a sort of from code,
a dataset of text
and annotations.
I have a similar another
function query data,
which takes a SQL query,
and just sends that SQL query
and returns a data frame.
And then I have,
a two more functions. One,
two more methods. One is,
upload the model, which
uploads, which both gives me
some type annotation that, like,
this is the type of model and
the type of vectorizer that I'm expecting.
And we'll,
and we'll sort of open
those files, or we'll, like,
write those models to disc and
then post those two files to
the model, up to the API.
And finally, I have a
method to score the model,
which is very simple.
It just takes the score model
endpoint and sends the text and,
and a last updated one that
just will tell me the last
updated time.
And the reason why
this is a kind of nice,
user experience
is that if I am,
then training the
model, for example,
I can have,
something like this at the top
of my, of my function here.
I have just an API instantiate
that API wrapper class. And then,
when I'm getting
new training data,
getting the up to date
training data, I'm going to use
this the API query data method.
So I don't really need to
know that this is an API.
I don't need to worry about making sure
I find my key in the right place,
assuming I'm storing it in
the environment variable that I'm
supposed to, it'll pick
it up in the right way.
And I don't need to think
that much about, you know, like,
what the htb response is or
turning some JSON into a data
frame in the right way will
kind of handle that all for me.
So the API is handling,
being the central source of
truth for where that model is.
And then the Python package
is building in some sort of
developer ergonomics to make my
user's life a little bit easier.
Okay. So let's give this a try.
This is a quarto document.
So I'm just gonna run
these piece by piece.
So I've got that running.
And this is gonna run.
It's gonna do a bunch of
things and output some, model metrics.
It gives me, like,
AUC, you know,
a couple of different metrics.
And then I'm gonna call,
try uploading this data.
And I uploaded this data and I
got a two hundred, so the data,
the two models have been
up updated to the API. Right?
So for the data scientists,
this is a really good interface.
I'm able to get updated
training data from this API.
I'm able to train my model,
I'm able to deploy my
model without leaving the place that
I want to without leaving the
interface that I want to use.
Right? I wanna use code,
wanna use maybe a Jupyter
notebook or VS Code to do this
type of interaction.
And so here, in terms of
where we're sitting, we have this,
this data store,
we have this API,
which is Python
in our packages,
and that's kind of or
this Python package,
and that kinda serves the data signed
if we wanted to build an ARPA package,
we would do it in more or
less the same way using,
httr or something,
to wrap the API.
So the next group of people
is let's let's tackle this
leadership group. And
because we've used quarto,
we've actually kind
of already done that.
So this is maybe a
really basic report,
but it is a report that shows
me, you know, what is the UC and,
the various different model
statistics that I might be
interested in for
this particular training run.
So how I could do that is
I could just deploy this quarto document.
So which I've
I've already done,
but I'll just show
you the process again.
I found it.
Oh, yeah. So electronics
model training. This is the,
the model training,
this is the sort of
model training, report that I'm
running. This is both
training the models.
Exactly the code at same code
I just showed you before.
And sort of assuming
this is maybe, like,
for a data science manager who
might be sort of familiar with
this code and wanna sort of
make sure that the people who
are training this model
are doing it correctly
And on the output,
it's sort of generating a
little bit of just basic scores.
You can enrich this by
turning it into a Quarto dashboard.
Or adding additional
plots or things like that.
For this case, just keeping
it very, very simple.
And this actually
whenever this,
code runs on Connect, it
is also uploading a model, right?
And since it's
uploading the model,
we can turn this really
easily into regular retraining service
by scheduling it.
So if I go over here and
click schedule this output for
default, and say I wanna
just retrain this model monthly.
So I'm gonna, sort
of, every month,
I'm gonna retrain the model,
you know, get the latest data,
maybe some data that's a
little bit time sensitive.
If we wanna or time time
dependent, we wanna have, like,
a recently trained model,
serving these these endpoints.
I'm able to do that. So if
I go ahead and save this,
then this is going to run
every month and generate these
training statistics every
month. And I can also have this
email to anybody in my
organization. So that gives you
that ability to sort of
keep people informed and also,
notify them when that
training has happened.
If we wanted to make this
a little bit more Rich, for
example, we could
also have an error,
check for certain qualities of
this model. So for example,
I could check that this
accuracy was not degrading or
let's say you see who's
not degrading and raise an
exception instead of
doing the model upload,
and then it would give
you sort of very basic
model monitoring for how your
training ones were doing.
Okay. So fairly easily, we've
kind of knocked out this top
part of the,
of the group. Right?
We have this this quarto
document that's running and
posting the model to the API.
Our leadership team can
read that quarto document.
And we have a good
code interface for our data
scientists, which both,
gives them the most
up to date model,
but also authenticates an to them
to the API in general and authorizes
that that particular
user. So, for example,
if one of these data scientists
had their laptops stolen,
we would probably the first
thing we would do is revoke
their Posit Connect key.
And if we revoke that
Posit Connect key,
then that would mean that they
wouldn't be able to access any
of this
modeling infrastructure.
But at the same time,
we have all of the nice
error messages and good ergonomics of
a well designed Python package.
So let's take a look
at this last group.
I'm gonna spend a little bit
more time on the code in this
one because, I think shiny
is maybe a newer thing,
maybe a little
bit less familiar.
To many people. So these
annotators are going to be
people who are just in
my company who are going to
manually check that the models
is producing a right the right
result and give and, sort of,
generate new training
data for me. Right?
This is one of the best
ways, especially for,
things like large language
models, just improving your
model. Most of the
time, you know,
you're not gonna be able to
do that much better from the model
selection or tuning
perspective than the defaults.
This is also true with
with XGboost most of the time.
If you just throw XGboost
at a tabular dataset,
it's gonna give you the best
a pretty good model for that dataset.
But if you give it
a better dataset,
then that's where you're
really gonna see a lot of lift.
So having the ability to build
in a patient capacity that is
quick and intuitive,
is very valuable.
And this annotation I want
this to use a web application.
I wanted to use a web
application because I want to
build that user interface
to make that annotation process
really fluid and fast.
So let's take a look at
the, the end results,
and then we can walk
through the code.
So this is the annotator.
Just going to take a minute to
to warm up because I think it's
starting a new process.
Or it's erroring. There we
go. Okay. So I just this is,
I I didn't this is a
spinning up a docker image or
Docker container.
So that's why it took
a little bit of time.
So this is the the
basic annotation
interface that I'm building.
We could imagine this
being more complicated,
but for now what it's doing is, it's pulling,
some random data from the,
from the dataset. And all
asking me, basically, is this,
like, about electronics,
not electronics,
or should I do I
want to just skip it?
And over here, I'm getting,
a model score out of it.
And this is letting me,
add some text to
it. If I do that,
it's going to sort of
automatically recalculate this model score.
For example,
I could change this to make
the model score update,
and it's gonna allow me to,
update this data.
Whenever I update,
it's gonna be a
little thing saying marked electronics,
and then pull up a new a
new one. So, this kind of lets me,
the annotator get
pretty quick at
reading it. Right? Cause I
could just look at this and
say, okay. That's electronics.
And, you know, I'm
I'm just, like,
getting the new stuff really quickly
and the UI is sort of
giving me the options
that I need. Right?
It's something I'm not
sure about. I could skip.
And, All of these,
things are referencing the
API that we just built. Right?
So the model score is
using the square end point.
This is pulling data from
the same data source.
And then when I mark
them as electronics or not electronics,
I am appending and I'm adding
new data to that, that code.
So let's take a look at
this in the application.
So the application is
somewhere here.
There we go. Shiny annotator.
So this is the shiny code.
And the thing I wanna
sort of highlight is how,
little is actually
happening on the server.
I'll sort of go through this
in a little bit more detail
but really, all I've got here
is I have this, update prompt
function that's being called, both
when they first log on
and, other places.
And,
and I have and that's kind
of and then I'm I'm calling the,
the model score. Right.
So what this update prompt
does is basically sends,
a text or sends a query
to the to the API.
To select a random record,
right, and then return that
string and update
the, the text area.
And the reason why this
is kinda working very well is
because all of the
logic is actually,
included in the API itself
and in that Python Right?
There's very little that I need
to include in the shiny app,
and the shiny app can just
be there for showing the UI code
and showing the
the interaction that I want
for that that, that code.
So let's walk through that
code a little bit here. So
So this is the app.
I can push this little play button
in VS Code to have it run.
And,
so what I have is I have,
a card with two rows and,
with a row and two columns.
And,
this card is including,
a, text area,
input, as well as, three
buttons for those electronics,
not electronics, and skip. And
then over here, I have the,
the model score output, which
is showing me the model score.
How this is, running as when
the, when the user first logs
in, I call update prompt
to update the, the text area.
And then,
these reactive
effects, which is,
how you respond to a button
input with a side effect, is
going to,
annotate the data with
whatever is in that text input.
And it's gonna use
the, session user,
which is the currently
logged in user on connect.
To populate the annotator field
and then give me a true or
false respectively.
And then I'm going to show that
notification and update the
prompt. So that's gonna
handle, annotating the data.
And the model score,
output is going to be just
a regular reactive. So whenever this changes,
so without other anything
other than just changing it,
I'm gonna call the API
and hit that model score.
And this works well, like,
that's fast enough because both
the API and the app are sitting
on more or less the same
server. So it's really
Posit connect talking into itself.
So there's not a lot of latency
between the API and the and the
server. So being able to have
a kind of reactive dynamic,
model score that's updating
all the time works fine.
And then when I actually
call the data annotation,
what I'm doing is just wrapping
that into to a data frame,
a one one row data frame,
and hitting the upload data API.
And we end up with
this, this tool here.
So this is a kind of useful,
and you can kinda see now
how this is all gonna work. Right?
So I'm going to have,
some set of data annotation
people in my company.
Maybe this is members of
the data team. Maybe it's, all
hands, let's go annotate
some data thing,
log in for twenty minutes,
and go just, like,
check a bunch of electronics
things to improve our model performance.
I'm gonna have a quarto
document that I'm using to
regularly rerender that data. So
whenever the, whenever the, the,
whenever this,
scheduled quarto document runs,
it's going to pick up
whatever the latest annotated data is
produced from these annotators
and, post a new model to
the API. And then everyone who's using
code first approach is going to
get access to that most up to
date best model that you have.
And because it's all
hosted on Posit Connect,
it's going to be authenticated
and authorized properly,
and I'm not going to need
to worry about security or
regulatory problems with it.
So I wanted to talk about
one final benefit of taking this
approach of splitting out,
some of your application
code from a Python package on
scripts into an API,
which is that it lets you move
things off of Connect very
easily. So for example, let's
say this API became very,
very popular. Right? I wanted
to deploy it to production.
And for a variety of reasons,
I don't wanna put Posit
Connect on my critical production path.
Right? There's a bunch
of reasons for that. Licenses,
how much licenses cost,
maybe it's a single server.
I don't wanna overload it.
And I probably also want to not
be responsible for it as a data scientists.
I want somebody else to handle
all the problems that come with
with implementing and scaling
in a consumer facing API.
But because I've started out with
this internal facing API, it's very,
very convenient for me to
hand that off to another developer.
Right? So this is a
FAST API, which is a,
tool which can robustly
does robustly serve,
demanding applications.
And I can say to some
dev ops person, look,
here I have this FAST API
thing. Can you go put it on
some sort of Kubernetes cluster to
serve lots and lots of people. Right?
Maybe you don't wanna
have all those endpoints,
but you wanna have
score model endpoint,
or maybe some other ones
that you're developing.
And the result is that
you can develop that API internally,
by using this, this structure.
And then when it's time to promote
that API and send it somewhere else,
you can just send that
over without really any type of
work. And you're sure sure
that it's going to be correct.
You're sure that it's going to,
handle the kind of the
load that it's probably that it
needs to handle kind of work through
a lot of the bugs and edge cases,
and are able to sort of
tell them, like, okay,
this is what you wanna do.
And if we did that, then,
all of the other parts of our
system would still work.
Right? We would just need to
update the endpoint in
this Python package, you know,
maybe redeploy the shiny app
and the Quarto document to
point to the right API.
But we would be able to,
to keep working with this thing
even though we took out one
part of this project and
just took it somewhere else.
In the same way,
if you wanted to,
replace this quarto
document with a more
sophisticated pipelining tool,
you wanted to use MLflow
or airflow to do model training
validation reporting,
you would still be able to
post from those from those
pipelines to this API to update
the model or update the data store.
Finally, if you wanted to host
you're Shiny app somewhere
else, again, you'd
be able to do that.
So having these types of
modular pieces will let you
take some swap some of them
in and out without a lot of
refactoring work.
And the term there,
that's really useful is
called, API contract,
which is basically the contractual,
the relationship that you're
promising to where where these
systems plug
together. So, like,
we're exposing some endpoints
to all these different things.
And so we're kind of
signing a contract that those endpoints
are gonna be stable. And
you know, maintain their thing,
even if where it's hosted
or what's happening under the hood
changes dramatically.
Those little points of contact
between these different
components of the system
will all be there.
Alright. Thank you very
much for, your time,
and I think I am going to
be able to take some questions now.
Absolutely. And thank
you so much, Gordon,
for the great demo and we'll jump
over to Q&amp;A here in just a second.
So it should automatically
push you over to the Q&amp;A room,
but if it doesn't, I'm gonna
share it in the chat here right
now. But again, when
you go over there,
you can ask questions in the
YouTube chat, but you can also
use this link shown
here on the screen,
for anonymous questions too.
Thank you again so much
for joining us today,
and I'll see you over
there in just a second.